I didn't even know
this place existed.
- I'm gonna have
my birthday party here.
- Yeah.
( music playing )
Marques invited me to this
incredible vintage warehouse
that has all kinds
of old Mac computers.
Specifically, the 1984 Mac,
which is something
that has a very special place
in my heart.
- Yeah, it's good.
- It's so great.
They don't make 'em
like they used to.
Do you wanna open it up?
So there are a few screws here.
- Should we go for it?
- I think we should
take it apart.
( muttering )
All right, final screw.
- Okay.
- Let's lift this off.
Do not touch the CRT coil
because you might get shocked.
Okay,
inside is the CRT monitor.
- It goes kinda far
into the body of it.
- Don't touch.
- Okay, I'm not gonna
touch the CRT coil.
- Don't. Mm-mm.
- I'll hold the bottom down.
- Okay.
- Ready?
- Yeah, yeah. Moment of truth.
Oh, man, look at this.
That is the inside
of a 1984 Mac.
That's the coil.
Don't touch the CRT.
There are two
different boards.
There's, to me unrecognizable,
mostly power components.
And then there's also a board
back here at the bottom,
which has
a lot more soldering.
- That's the floppy drive.
- The system disk
is the floppy disk,
so that basically
loads it into the RAM.
And as soon as you take
that disk out, it's gone.
You're basically
loading things as it goes.
And it would be
a combination of reading
from the memory that it
has preloaded things into
and that floppy disk.
This only had 128K of RAM.
What, now it's
a thousand times smaller?
One front facing selfie
on the iPhone,
- Yeah?
- you couldn't even
fit it on here.
Like, that's insane.
Steve Jobs had created this
as a work of art.
So, in most art,
people sign them.
- True.
- So, inside of here
are autographs
- of all the people
that worked on this team.
- Oh, that's cool.
- So you can see them
right there.
- And they're subtle.
All these little
inscriptions.
That's actually
a nice little touch,
signing your work.
I'm glad we learned
all this today.
Thank you so much
for helping me
take apart this Mac
and for giving me
the breakdown.
- Appreciate it.
- Thank you so much.
This was seriously
amazing. Wow.